if you ever wondered who the next Steph
Curry will be think we might have found
him meet casay tominaga the 6-2 Nebraska
guard who is given a nickname Japanese
Steph Curry Kay is currently lighting up
at Nebraska averaging 14 points he has
dreams of playing in the NBA and his
dreams aren't as far fast as you think
Kay grew up watching the NBA and modeled
his game after his favorite player Steph
Curry but basketball has always been in
his blood because his dad played center
for Japan's national team he even
encouraged Kay to play over Siege and of
course Kay following his dad's footsteps
by recently making his National debut in
the summer of 2022 but his career Ranger
College where everything took off he
averaged 16.8 points per game and when
Scouts took notice in 2021 they gave him
a full scholarship to Nebraska ever
since then it's been all about his game
he shot 40% from three last season he
dropped a season High 28 points against
Indiana to give Nebraska his first win
over the HOA since 2017 so no matter the
kind of odds against him to get drafted
Kay is already proven he's ready for any
challenge